another turnover forced by the Bucks
right under the basket he fenced himself
to the deck finding his helper out of
the break Yanis taking out probably
about done for the night at mines will
throw a little windmill down
hey coach but saw the way you came down
and said alright that's enough come on
[Music]
[Applause]
getting down the Bucks is offensive
efficiency well it's pretty simple as
you see honest flush
[Applause]
they'll off the basketball before the
red light comes on
yes he did I told you it was good Wow
whoa
where's up on the honesty honest tight
together love forcing to throw away
let's Oh
[Applause]
see
since Yanis trilling siakam not quitting
on the play that's been a very solid
second game as a blazer for Carmelo
Anthony ten point lead man look at this
play baseline spin reverse dunk tack
Corky and Jen flushed him Wow almost
vintage look how high he was on that
[Applause]
right to LeBron and he says a I'm taking
this you see the shot clock up there
were 22 on it when he went through the
net
[Applause]
another great Showtime feed from James
to Dwight
Russo plays little tea man keep away
[Applause]
reefer stuff says I see what you're
going to do is go to the rim I'll just
throw it up and you do the rest and cook
do the wrist he does
hose it down - he yeah many tickets
remaining for that game tomorrow night
so get on
great defense leading to that George
Hill
[Applause]
makers get that designers goes quickly
chased out
[Applause]
the job of getting back and preventing
an easy dues to the day Vincenzo's done
giving Dante his first points in the
game
[Applause]
and again Jim Boylan takes and out of
the khumba streak against Chicago in the
52 year history
to switch left over each language
I mean that pass couldn't have been any
better bounds by kcpt LeBron
look how perfectly that but I love Ron
was he come on oh that was nice Lakers
have 10 points in the paint already in
this game
[Applause]
to Houston please show us that again
that's a little bit of Dominique off one
leg he used to double pump it bring it
down there's some new stop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
300 thousands on the line here grant
with 6%
[Applause]
that's fitting in your show you meet
your bail rejected by McGee teams goes
behind the back and then reverse layup
is good and it's Davis who pulls down
the rebound out duals LeBron for that
board the last couple of games he's made
of both James nearly walk Howard throws
it back up top to Davis
Danny Green - James James gets in the
pane and finishes
Middleton just for for 15 from the field
James finding his spot goes inside wipes
out CF deep Lopez's and look at Magee
he's not rolling to try to get a pass
from James because he knows Lopez is so
deep there's no roll going to be
available he rolls to try to take out
the shot blocker
[Applause]